[Music]  okay first first memory of SNL  I assume this this means like as a child  growing out probably Dana Carvey  chopping broccoli probably lazy Sunday  all my friends were rapping in I looked  it up and it was an SNL digital short I  remember it was like when the best of  and my sisters were cracking up chopping  broccoli I didn't even get the joke but  it was just like a funny sounding thing  weirdly my first memory of SNL is martin  shorts character ed Grimley i remember  going to the studio tour NBC and ed  Grimley was like the one character that  was like so excited about first memory  of SNL I believe is watching opera man  Adam Sandler do opera man I'm Weekend  Update like all my parents were laughing  this was like the peak of Wayne's World  when it became a really big thing when  that kind of venture zeitgeist moment  when I became aware of the show and it's  a good memory fake one see more videos  like this subscribe in GQ channel  you